you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is round
nine from the 2013 World Chess
Championship match between the mountain
and Carlsen
going into this round Carlson has a 5 to
3 lead over Anand this is a race to six
and a half points to determine a world
champion and Anand with the white pieces
and this one opened with d4 this is the
first time he's played this all their
moves it was efore when he had white but
coming right out needing a win trying d4
and soon enough on board we have the
nimzo-indian defense and to be more
exact the Komachi variation with f3
looking to build the center black
interferes with this idea and now a
question is thrown to the bishop to take
or to go elsewhere going elsewhere keep
in mind allows efore to be played much
more freely and we can have this
structure but that's not a road we go
down instead black wastes no time
invests the bishop pair damages the
white structure and well now - well now
look to put pressure on the d4 point c5
is played right away and it may seem
counterintuitive to do that keep in mind
White has the bishop pair isn't this
just welcoming exchanges when you're the
side who doesn't have the bishop pair so
why is that even played well it involves
keeping pressure on d4 and by doing so
you interfere with what White's plan
will be to get the e4 break in keep in
mind that even if this pun is supported
enough and it could play to e4 well
notice how after this captured the Queen
would be a third piece that would be
around to put pressure on the d4 point
so clearly there's not enough support
for it just yet but I'm looking more
long-term the idea will be to make sure
you put pressure on d4 first some
clarification in the center and with III
the bishop now looks to play - a nice
diagonal where it would support the e4
advance this structure by the way is one
that is a we we see we saw in a very
popular game
from 1938 Botvinnik versus capablanca
Botvinnik playing the white side winning
a very nice game it involved getting in
this central expansion and a really nice
game to certainly check out but in this
one much different because we don't have
the Bishop on d3 just yet and so where
will he reside well we will see that
soon enough but before I point that out
notice what this pond is doing it's not
just stopping the bishop from getting on
this diagonal it's watching over b3 as
well it's allowing this Queen Knight to
be annoying to the White Queen side and
at the same time it's releasing the
pressure on d4 so all of a sudden maybe
that's not so much a concern for white
right if efore is played there's not
going to be the d4 point that's weakened
without the C pawn around putting
pressure on it
so II four could be played without any
concern about the d4 square so black is
weighing that it would be better to
inconvenience the bishop grab some space
and look to camp out on b3 92 is it the
Knights are developed classically g4 is
insert inserted first before playing the
knight to g3 so that Bishop g2 could be
played and this also brings a question
to the knight is he so stable anymore on
the f6 square he has to wonder where his
next home will be should g5 be played
black castles Bishop g2 here comes the
Queen Knight white castles the rook is
hit functioning better on a 2 opposed to
b1 so that it has some lateral movement
and now black sets into motion their
majority three versus two this is a very
very nice game something that is
reminding me of Game four of this match
where we saw the whole chessboard being
made use of action on the Kings side the
center as well as the Queen side where
there is a majority here for black
looking forward to a5 b4 and one of
these two pawns one of the black pawns b
pond or c pond will become
and in the meantime what white will look
to do is advance on the kingside white
is looking to checkmate
the black king so it is first Knight g3
here comes black and with g5 the knight
is kicked back to EA keep in mind that
this move is also allowing for rook a6
some lateral movement for the rook
something I overlooked during the game
it's not just to get this majority
rolling but some interesting lateral
defense with the rough pivoting on a6 is
maybe available and so we did have g5
during the game I thought about this
sacrifice and well I overlooked that
there is this defense if the bishop is
in fact playing to g5 to pin the night
and I also underestimated maybe this
idea at some point by black b4 by making
this C pawn flinch well d4 is close to
crumbling so it's not without some
drawbacks certainly there's activity for
the white pieces but black has their
chances and well as well in such a
position so we don't see that white does
not give up any material instead kicks
the knight back and now as the follow-up
efore and up until this point you'll
know the night is never taking the
bishop he's superior to the bishop at
this point where I mean where is he
going to go if he he plays to d2 you
could always take him if he's trying to
run away and if he's going to be - well
that just looks weird he's not doing
anything and also interferes with the
rook so you'll know only after ephors
played and the bishop has a couple ways
to escape the Knights capture well now
he's taken Queen takes rook lifts and
now comes a five so soon we're going to
have three pawns maybe in the black
position currently - White has a great
space advantage over black on the King
side and what will black look to do
black will look to get in b4 get the
majority still rolling create some past
pawn on the Queen side but soon enough
we're going to have a group of
potentially three pawns in the black
position on this fifth rank
that's a very menacing group of pawns
and how is black going to approach this
situation well its first Knight c7 and
that was played with a great deal of
thought how much about 21 minutes was
invested on this move and so what was
what else was being considered well
notice how with E 5 its f5 that has been
weakened and so G 6 is a move that cries
out to control that square and then to
follow up with Knight g7 watching over
f5 now how could white follow up well we
can have f4 97 but as Carlsen pointed
out in the press conference he didn't
like this idea of Queen B 1 pressure on
b5 and also keeping a watchful eye over
f5 playing a move like Queen d7 to
defend both of these squares is a bit
awkward it is not a road he chose to go
down keep in mind there would be
additional pressure like so he didn't
want to enter this structure wanted
something different he kept his pawns
sitting in other words he didn't touch
them until this pawn eventually gets to
f6 and we do get to see that in this
game and with that pot on f6 white again
is really looking for the King's throat
looking to give checkmate on g7 Knight
c7 is played f4 is played b4 is played
King side play Queen side play pawns are
exchanged the night is now
inconvenienced far away from the defense
of the black King f5 is now played a
group of three pawns and with that
clears the way for the Queen to pivot on
f4 get to h4 with f6 g6 Queen h6 again
looking for maid on g7 b3 first I
thought that this was a possibility to
eliminate this pawn so the knight can
maybe hop into d3 by way of b4 but not
the direction black goes in b3 instead
connected past pawn the b-pawn just two
steps away from queening and now this
night better hurry back since these two
squares are
ruled out 87 in response to Queen f4 f6
is played weakening the dark squares
breaking down the structure a giant
thorn in the black position will there
be a defense of g7 Queen h4 just in the
nick of time the knight is there on EI
t' to defend against g7 there were two
squares where you could have defended
against g7 and I had thought this might
have also been a way to defend but
notice how he is accessible to the white
pieces when he's on e6 after Queen h6 I
thought maybe Queen c7 so that even if
the knight is captured there could be
capture with the pawn on f7 for example
after Bishop b7 I thought you could do
this and then after the recapture the
Queen would be there to defend this is
often a good way to defend but not in
this position because there are other
possibilities that are available to
white the bishop when it plays to h3 is
not looking necessarily to capture the
knight but to support a knight hop into
f5 for example Bishop d7 Knight f5 if
he's taken mate will follow soon enough
on h7 and if the knight is not taken
well look what he's ready to do give
check and then big trouble so for
example rook here well notice how
there's Knight d6 and well what are you
going to do if the rook plays here
there's a really nice tactical shot of
Knight takes f7 this is simply crumbling
for black if King takes well we're
taking the night if King takes bishop is
just simply falling apart so the idea
here is to not make the knight
accessible to capture you don't place
the night honey 6 you go to eh he's more
reliable to defend over g7 but what to
do now about this rook lift where white
could give me on h7 well b2 interferes
with this idea if Rukh f4
black is able to get a queen with check
that's what we see on the board rook f4
is played allowing Carlsen to obtain yet
another Queen to Queens but white is
going right for the Kings throughout
will there be a defense Knight f1 is
played and this was a serious blunder so
much so that after Queen to e1 Anand
resigned
there is no rook h4 the Queen will just
take the rook out rook h4 this is just
an extra piece and now there's
absolutely no mate against the black
King just like that
game over the better try would have been
to interpose with the bishop
since rook e1 or Queen e1 while you're
still playing here and it's black who
goes down maybe well no there's not even
a there's not going to be some perpetual
check I don't believe in this position
this is going to turn out to be a mate
there's Queen III King g2 and well what
else is there some check here you can
block with the bishop nothing is a being
done here still about the threat of made
on h7 so we wouldn't have of course if
the bishop blocks we wouldn't have Queen
e1 but what we would have is Queen d1
this was the better try of course what
would follow is rook h4 another Queen is
able to sneak back to interpose on h5
what a fantastic resource this is Knight
takes Queen pawn takes Knight rook takes
and now notice with that pond no longer
around on g6 Bishop f5 is there just in
the nick of time to defend h7 look at
the minor pieces in the role they are
serving watching over the Kings defense
Bishop h3 tries to kick the bishop away
and you best not play Queen d7 because
of this killer shot g6 big trouble here
for team black if we have this sort of
capture he's going down like this you
could have some fun and see how exactly
White's gonna win here this is I guess
one quick way to do it so you need to be
very cautious
at this point right here if the bishop
is challenged you don't play Queen d7
you just tuck the bishop back and if you
are now having EE 6 well we can invest
some material to release the pressure
the black pieces are springing about and
at the end of it this is going to be a
much better approach by white but black
is still up upon but has some issue here
with upon on e6 Bishop back here as a
defense
we didn't go down that road there is one
other possibility at this point right
here after Knight takes pawn takes if
Bishop here not allowing the bishop to
defend by way of f5 well notice how
there could be this capture and then
after Queen b6 white is ready to give me
just a moment away but there's a timely
check and the Queen can always if right
back and defend so there wouldn't be a
good way to go about things if Bishop is
playing to h3 first instead of capturing
on h5 but as it was in this game we had
it ending much more abruptly after the
promotion it is the knight block and
after Queen to e1 Anand ends up
resigning and this match is now set at 6
points for Carlsen three points for
Anand a huge mountain to climb nearly
insurmountable Carlsen needing now only
a half a point to become the world
champion so we will see soon enough and
as always I hope you got something out
of this video take care bye
you